[Music]
in my experience most CEOs and boards
get the power of diversity you know
there may be some who are giving it lip
service still out there
but in my travels these individuals
understand that not only is it the fair
thing to do and it's really the tenants
upon which our country was built but
it's really the smart thing to do
financial results reaching different
customer bases I think they get it
sadly middle management is where
diversity goes to die and I've been
thinking about this a lot recently
because there's research I've recently
come across that says that diversity is
actually worse in meritocracies it's
really surprising right you'd think you
know meritocracy people will search out
the best person will search out the best
you know strategy and will judge them
later and the capitalism the market
forces will decide huh but it's worse in
meritocracies and I think it is exactly
that sort of hands-off perspective that
if you're a CEO you get it you're hiring
all the time etc but you're in middle
management you're hiring what once a
year twice a year for you know four
times a year once every few years it's
it can it's not a regular part of the
job and the research tells us that while
there are these supposed benefits to
diversity that we tend to retreat to the
comfortable we tend to overvalue
products that we already have we tend to
overvalue environments in which we
already exist and by the way the longer
we have it or exists in the more we
overvalue them and so what you see in
the middle management is I like working
with people like me and in Mena maybe I
read some research report one time that
said diversity was better but gosh I
like Jim right gosh I like him compound
that with that we tend to allow
ourselves in this country to ask the
wrong question and the question we
usually ask when hiring people is can
you help me find the best person for the
job
the best person for the job our
cognitive shortcuts is typically someone
who reminds us so darn much of ourselves
whereas what we should be asking is can
you help me fill out the best team right
build the best team with diverse skill
sets etc so as a CEO my advice is
changing my advice is to often override
the meritocracy that this desire to let
your managers manage honey and we tried
it right nothing more meritocratic than
Wall Street and look what happened
they're the most homogeneous of
environments and of financial crisis and
so to put metrics out there to pay
managers on diversity is I think the
only way to drive it and as for the old
Diversity Committee which you sort of
did that ten years ago and look we're
working on diversity because we have it
if you've got something in place for
five and ten years and your diversity is
not moving for it it's time to stop it
it's time to do something different to
change the tired mentoring program into
a sponsorship program you know to set
those quotas - I know we hate the word
quota to set those those goals to pay
people on those goals to try to do
something that's different
PS it's not a pipeline issue it's not a
lack of talent issue you know they're
there plenty of women there plenty of
professional women there plenty of
people of all kinds of diverse cognitive
perspectives out there it's not just
letting bringing them in and letting the
organization work the organization is
working against you there is no doubt in
my mind that the financial crisis that
the United States and the world suffered
would have been less severe if we'd had
more diversity on Wall Street there's no
doubt we know this intuitively if all of
us think about those cavernous trading
floors where the individuals populating
the trading desks looked the same that
if those had been
you know incredibly diverse sort of the
United Nations of every different kind
of person you could have we intuitively
know that the crisis would have been
less severe we intuitively know that if
there were more women at the senior
leadership tables that the crisis would
have been less severe and not only do we
know it intuitively the research tells
us this the research tells us that
homogenous teams tend to over trust each
other we cognitively finish each other
sentences oh she's just like me or he's
just like me so therefore since we look
and talk and act alike and have a set of
shared experiences I understand what
you're thinking and what what you'll do
next and so homogeneous markets tend to
be mispriced by tens of percentage
points the other thing that the research
tells us is that trading risk can be
driven by testosterone and that as
gentlemen's testosterone increases they
take on more trading risk as it reduces
less trading risky you know who doesn't
have a lot of testosterone women women
and it's funny because we women get that
rap for being so emotional and so
hormone driven but in fact what the
research tells us is you can track the
risk with testosterone not estrogen you
know we're sitting here today in the
early months of the Trump administration
and the pictures of the leadership are
startling and striking in that it is not
unusual to see a picture of all white
males whether that's all white males
huddled around you know the Oval Office
huddled around the president on the
telephone or whether it's all white
males making decisions about our health
care sitting here in these early months
of the Trump administration I think you
would be hard-pressed to say that the
administration is running efficiently
effectively like a well-oiled machine
taking into account the complexity of
what it's trying to do there have been
several important missteps and there's
no way to my mind those things are
unrelated and the research would tell us
that they are indeed related
[Music]